hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masid a daa center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even more
[Music]
how are you guys doing before I start
this video and ask zishan some very
pertinent questions that we here in the
west and everyone else in the world need
to know about Vis A V the Bangladesh
situation what's happening in Bangladesh
with the students I want to First
congratulate my good brother zishan for
his reaching 1 million subscribers he
definitely deserves it he's been putting
uh a lot of effort into his work bro and
actually our work as well you've helped
us uh and free of charge you've done it
without any um you you haven't you
haven't asked for a penion and I want I
want to thank you in front of the people
for that but um this our job you know as
Muslim Brothers as people in the da
scene this is an exemplification of our
tradition this is this is what we do for
the sake and you got you got patreon I
mean I think the people will be able to
find it somehow is if you help his
patreon you're helping not just him but
you're helping me Ali him everyone cuz
he's this studio we're using it free of
charge we're not he's not you know and
the the the editing and the graphics and
yeah let's go to the Bangladesh issue in
it okay so uh on this point bro um
you've got your own News company now
which is uh yourj news.com yeah you're
delivering News free of charge to the
public right and um it's been doing very
well and you have like editors and um
researchers and stuff like that you've
done the research on this let's for just
basic stuff here bro people are just
they're a bit confused I think what's
going on in
Bangladesh quite simply if I was to
break it down yeah you've got government
jobs sure these are very prestigious
they have Perks and this is what people
go for yeah but what the government has
done is it's assigned quotas and
assigned it to certain people of society
could be you know ex relatives of EX
soldiers and other groups and that's
actually cut the p
for everybody else who are making the
argument that these are very important
and integral jobs okay at a time of
economic so is that they done the
protest yeah at the time of economic
drought we want you guys to make it
Merit based okay yeah let us also have a
chance of getting those jobs because we
also have mouths to Fe and are these
protests happening throughout like
Bangladesh these these protests actually
initially started off um small they
started off with students unarmed
students yeah but the government started
getting heavy-handed really and
heavy-handed to such a degree that the
death toll has increased so much that
the official figures 150 have been
killed my god um but the media is saying
200 my god well bro I mean this this is
actually very very concerning because uh
you if there's someone you don't want to
upset as a government of a country it's
the students of universities because
these guys are not only going to be the
next generation and help out the country
in the most important way but they are
going to be the most influential people
potentially so you're what you're doing
is you're creating resentment okay in
the subsection of society which you need
to take care of the most it makes
absolutely no sense whoever is advising
the government it's not just unethical
what they're doing and Haram and all of
those things yes but it's also it's not
even expedient it's not even pragmatic
it's not even tactful it's not even
strategic so it's it's shocking what's
happening and there needs to be more
noise about this let me tell you what
actually makes it more shocking the fact
is that not only has there been security
forces that have been targeting students
remember initially they were unarmed
yeah they're students for God's sake I
mean what are they going to have yeah
sticks and stones and then now even the
Army compasses and rulers and and
calculators yeah and now even the Army
is getting involved as as well you're
seeing helicopters you're seeing tear
gas to such a degree that um LA Times
said that they have been given well
there's a curfew now and the uh the the
police or the Army have been given shoot
on site orders really I mean to such a
degree that the BBC bro have have said
that the hospitals there have been
inundated because I've just given you
150 to 200 that have been killed there
have been many these are live rounds
these are even some say you know they
are rubber bullets or this or that but
they are injured people with gunshot
wounds that are inundating hospitals and
they it's it's just too much I mean it's
it's it's actually sickening and
disturbing to to know that this is
happening to our brothers and sisters in
in Bangladesh and definitely our prayers
are with them how can we help the
situation bro well even before we even
look at how we can help them bro it's
would is there any chance of the
government curtailing and stopping at
the moment and the answer is very
pessimistic rather and even the neighbor
of Bangladesh India they've said this
was on DW news they're saying yeah this
is an internal Bangladeshi matter we
don't want to get involved they don't
want to get involved because they feel
that the current leader Hina who's been
you know voted in for a fourth time even
though the opposition party were
boycotting you know um her current yeah
entrance
and the thing is India sees Bangladesh
as a buffer between itself and China and
it doesn't see it being easily
accessible to China so India is taking
very strategic moves and which is very
unsurprising because of the Indian BJP
government which are oppressing its
minorities as well so hey India seems
like it's at home of course India is not
going to be involved because Bangladesh
isn't involved in their issues so when
you're seeing uh and even over here as
well K what did he say oh yeah
Bangladesh is this was before he got
voted in yeah so it's not really looking
good and that's why we're seeing our
comment section inundated with our
Bangladeshi brothers and sisters because
they are trying to
raise some sort of voice on the
Grassroots level just so at least they
will see because there is again uh the
internet gets cut off as well there's
limiting of websites think Facebook was
down even WhatsApp was down so limiting
the sort of information that will reach
us here and this again we had to
research and really look into it and um
spend our time finding out what's going
on information is not widely accessible
and videos because the government is
clamping down so yeah it's not it's not
looking good may Allah make it easy for
our brothers and sisters I guess you're
saying what can we do for them just
speak out uh anytime something happens
post about it talk about it at the very
least if we do have uh you know access
to the counselors and MPS we should get
them to obviously raise these sorts of
things in Parliament as well as much as
can be done if there are any um protests
taking place here because protests
aren't IL legal over here then um
definitely do them but of course do it
peacefully we don't want to ruin the the
the genuine cause of uh the the
Bangladesh's students frankly they are
students
yeah so whether you're Pakistani whether
you're Indian whether you're Arab
whether you're black white green blue
whoever it is this is not a matter of
yeah this is a Bangladesh issue this is
this is a matter of human issue frankly
and uh we pray for our brothers and
sisters in in Bangladesh as we do for
brothers and SS in Sudan and Palestine
everywhere
else your brothers and sisters in Islam
net from Norway are establishing a Masid
a DA Center this Center this Masid this
educ educational institution will act
like a beacon of light calling the
Muslims in Norway back to the essence of
Islam so give generously and Allah will
give you even more